NICOLA MARZARI: Wonderful.
OK.
So welcome to class 5.
We are actually counting the
lab as class 4 in the numbering.
What we'll see today
is really a wrap-up
on some of these ideas on
the behavior of electrons
as quantum particles.
And we'll introduce really
the first electronic structure
method in the modern sense--
that is Hartree-Fock theory--
that you'll see as a very
simple, conceptual framework.
And it really derives directly
from the Schrodinger equation
and from the reformulation
of the Schrodinger equation
as a variational principle.
Next class, we'll start with
density functional theory.
That is a completely
different approach
to the problem
than Hartree-Fock.
Although, in
practice, it results
in equations for the wave
function of the electron
that are formerly fairly simple.
Historically, Hartree-Fock
has been the method
that has developed first,
especially from the quantum
chemistry community.
And because it derives from
the variational principle,
it can actually be augmented
with perturbation theory.
So whenever you need very
accurate calculations,
things like molar
[INAUDIBLE] approaches
and other perturbation
theory approaches
on top of Hartree-Fock
can actually help you out.
But they tend to
be very expensive.
OK.
Let me, in one slide, remind you
of the most fundamental concept
from last class
that we have seen.
That is the de Broglie relation.
This is something that tells
us that if a particle has
a momentum mass times
velocity p, well,
then there is a fundamental
constant in nature that is
called the Planck constant--
that's written here--
such that this
relation is satisfied
where lambda is the
wavelength of that particle.
So basically, particles
have wavelength properties.
But the real issue is that
only electrons are light enough
to have wavelength comparable
to the inter-atomic distance,
so to give rise to
diffraction phenomena.
And so this is why
we actually need
to treat the electrons with
the Schrodinger equation
due to their
wavelike properties.
And in general, we don't
really need to nuclei
as a wave-like particle.
So this was one thing.
The other important thing that
I'll repeat over and over again
is that when we move from a
particle-like description,
where the only
important quantity are
the position and the momentum,
to a wave-like quantity, well,
we have a completely different
computational content.
That is, a wave
function is actually
defined by assigning the
amplitude of the wave
at every point in space
and at every time.
So in practice, it's a continuum
field that in every, say,
computational calculation
needs actually
to be discretized and
approximated in different ways.
And then I introduced
what is the equivalent
of the Newton's second law of
dynamics for actually quantum
objects.
So classical particles evolve
according to the law force
equals mass times
acceleration, where
the acceleration is really
the secondary derivative
of the trajectory.
Quantum particles obey a
different fundamental law
that's basically been discovered
by Erwin Schrodinger in 1925.
And the other major player where
Werner Heisenberg, Paul Dirac,
and many others.
And I've written it here
in the most general form
for the case of a single
electron, so a particle
that is described
by a wave function
psi, a function
of space and time.
Very good.
The machine [INAUDIBLE] beep.
OK.
Professor Ceder will
take care of this.
And let me continue.
So we have the descriptor
that is the wave function.
And we have a potential.
A potential is the
general concept.
It could be, say, the
electromagnetic potential
that is coming from
the nucleus of an atom.
So suppose that you are
studying a hydrogen atom.
Well, the nucleus has
an attractive potential
for the electron that is
just 1 over the distance
between the electron
and the nucleus.
So V here is really
the same potential
that you have learned
in classical dynamics
and electromagnetism.
But now, instead of
acting on a particle,
it acts on the wave function.
And the way it does, it just
multiplies the wave function.
So what the Schrodinger
equation is telling
me is that whenever
I have a potential V,
the solution for the
dynamics of the electron
will be given by the solution of
this second-order differential
equation, where here
this is a Laplacian.
We have a second derivative
with respect to space.
And so the wave function needs
to satisfy this equation.
In most cases, to actually
deal with problems
in which the potential
does not depend on time--
suppose that you are
studying a molecule.
What is your potential?
Think of, say, the
benzene molecule.
Well, you have six carbon atoms
in a ring and six hydrogen
atoms also in a ring.
And in each nucleus,
there is a Z/r
that is an attractive
potential for the electron.
And that we can either
think of at a potential
that doesn't change in time--
or even if it changes,
because the molecule is
a certain temperature and
so atoms move around, what
it turns out will
happen in practice
is that electrons are so
much lighter than nuclei
that for all practical
purposes they
move so much faster that
they see the nuclei basically
as fixed in time.
So if you think of a
particle like a nucleus that
has a huge mass and a
particle like an electron that
has a very light mass, well,
even if the nuclei move,
the electrons always
are so much faster
to rearrange themselves to
be in the minimum energy
configuration.
We'll actually see
more of what is
called adiabatic approximation.
So the important
thing here is that,
for all practical purposes,
we consider in most problems
the potential as not
really dependent on time
either because the
atoms are not moving
or because even if they
move, they move so much more
slowly than the electrons.
Then the electrons can
always [INAUDIBLE]..
The form that the wave
function can have.
And I'll briefly sketch
out this derivation here.
So whenever the potential
doesn't depend on time,
this is how we proceed.
We actually make an
hypothesis-- often,
this is called an ansatz--
in which our wave
function can actually
be separated into the
product of two terms--
a term that depends
only on space,
we'll call it phi; and a term
that depends only on time.
So we are making
this hypothesis.
We have decided that
the potential does not
depend on time.
And we see what [AUDIO OUT].
What we have now
is that whenever
we apply, say, the Laplacian
secondary derivative
with respect to space,
well, [INAUDIBLE]
the f component of the function,
the time-dependent component.
So the Laplacian of psi
can be written actually
as f times the Laplacian of phi.
And then I'm not writing
the explicit dependence
on the variables.
But we have the potential
times the wave function, phi f.
And then we have i h bar.
And now, the derivative with
respect to time of phi--
well, a phase-dependent
part is not affected.
So we write it as
pih times df/dt.
OK.
So this is our first step.
And now, we take
this expression.
And we just divide it by
the product of phi times f.
And so when I do
that, what I obtain
is minus h bar squared divided
by 2m Laplacian of phi divided
by phi plus V equal
to i h bar 1/f df/dt.
And this really is the
end of the derivation
because something very
important happens at this point.
Look for a moment at
the right-hand side
of this equation.
You see it's just a constant--
the Planck constant, i,
is the imaginary unit--
times 1/f df/dt.
So everything that's written
on the right-hand side here
depends only on time.
The left-hand side,
on the other hand,
we have a term that
depends only on position.
Phi is a function of position.
And V-- remember, our
initial hypothesis--
does not depend on time.
The potential does
not depend on time.
So the left-hand
side [AUDIO OUT]..
Now, the only way such a
relation can be satisfied--
that is a term dependent
solely on position can be equal
to a term that
depends only on time--
is if each term separately.
That's the only way the
overall function of r
can be [AUDIO OUT]
overall function of t,
if they are constant.
Basically, because r and t
are independent variables,
there is no relation.
If you want, in this
ansatz [AUDIO OUT] down
the Schrodinger
equation in two parts--
the left part being
equal to a constant,
and the right part being
equal to a constant.
So there is a simplification.
We can deal with
separate equations
for the time-dependent part and
for the space-dependent part.
What is the left-hand term
equal to a constant becomes
what is called the stationary
Schrodinger equation.
That is the equation
that we'll try
to solve over and over
again in our calculation.
And it's the term that
I've written here.
So the stationery Schrodinger
equation is written here.
And this is the
differential equation
that, in principle,
is complex to solve
because the potential can have
an arbitrary complex shape.
But again, think
of the potential
as being the
attractive potential
for the electrons generated by
all the nuclei in a molecule
or in a solid.
And the time [AUDIO OUT] has
become trivial to integrate.
And we see this is the time part
of the Schrodinger equation.
We see, actually,
in the next slide
why this is simple
because this is just
a first-order
differential equation.
And we are looking, in
general, for a function
whose first derivative
with respect to time
is equal to the function
itself times a constant.
[AUDIO OUT] equation
to integrate
because the exponential function
satisfies this condition.
When you take the
exponential, you just
get the exponential
itself times a constant.
And so really, there is
no analysis [AUDIO OUT]
The other part, the
space-dependent part
is the one that is
complex to solve.
And we'll see here just a
few examples [AUDIO OUT]
If we want the simplest
example possible,
that is the case
of a free particle.
What happens to an electron
that doesn't feel any potential?
And again, its wave
function is going
to be the product of a
space-dependent part phi
times a time-dependent part f.
The f term [AUDIO OUT].
The space-dependent term
here is the solution
of the stationary Schrodinger
equation in the hypothesis
that the potential
V is equal to 0.
So I've removed from the
stationary [AUDIO OUT]..
Again, this is a fairly
simple differential equation
to integrate because what we
are looking for is basically
a function whose
secondary derivative is
equal to the function
itself times a constant.
And then again, the solution is
just given by an exponential,
OK?
Now, I'm looking in particular
at the problem in which I'm
trying to find a solution phi
for a value of this constant E
that is positive.
And so when you actually
work out the algebra,
you see that what you
need as a term in front
of the x in the exponential
is the square root
of a negative number,
of twice the mass times E
divided by h bar squared.
And so that's why we get
this imaginary unit here.
It's basically because we
have rewritten this equation
as the square Laplacian of
phi equal to minus 2mE divided
by h bar squared f.
And you see
straightforwardly that if you
take the secondary whatever
of the functions that
are written here,
well, we'll get,
by taking the first
derivative, a term
i square root of 20
divided by h bar.
And when we take the
second derivative,
we get that term again.
And the square of that
term is a square of i
that gives you my minus sign.
OK.
So this is the solution.
We have actually found the wave
function for our free particle.
And the wave function
is the product
of [AUDIO OUT] times
the time-dependent part.
And in the next
slide, I am actually
plotting this wave
function in space.
Sorry, let me jump
to this slide.
This is it.
So I am plotting it.
For simplicity, I've called
it a different coefficient.
E over h bar, I've
called it omega.
And square root of 2mE divided
by h bar, I've called it t.
So this is the wave function
for a free electron.
And this is what we
call a plane wave.
And the reason why
is that is simple
because if you think
of what this term is,
the exponential of
a complex number
is really a combination
of sines and cosines.
And now, suppose that you look
at the amplitude of this wave
function at a certain
point in space--
that is at a certain
x equal to x0.
What you see is
that that amplitude
will have a kx factor that
doesn't change because we
are sitting at a certain x0.
But what is changing
with respect to time
is the second term, omega t.
And so you see an oscillating
amplitude with a period
omega at any point in time.
Or in a different
way, if for a moment
you think that what is this
field of the wave function
at a frozen instant in time--
that is for a certain
time t equal to t0--
well, it's nothing else
than a complex exponential.
So it's a
complex-valued function
that has a cosine or sine
projection, depending
if we look at the
real or complex axes.
So what you need
to think of when
you think that at
a free electron
is nothing else than
this infinite oscillatory
field propagating in space.
But it has really no
beginning and no end.
And one of the important things
is that the wave function
really contains all the
information that we might
want to know about an electron.
And we will see
in the next slides
how we actually obtain
the physical properties
about an electron
from the function.
But the simplest
property in [AUDIO OUT]
of finding an electron
in a certain position
and a certain time.
And so [INAUDIBLE] that
wave function amplitude
at a certain x and
a certain t gives me
actually the
physical probability
of finding an electron.
That means that if I have the
wave function of an electron,
I can take at every
point in space
the square models
of its amplitude.
And so what I have now is
a probability distribution.
And what quantum
mechanics tells me
is that if I'm going
to make a measurement
and try to see where
the electron is,
well, I will find it
in different points
in space with a
probability [AUDIO OUT]
into these square models.
And you see one of the first
conclusions from our analysis
of the Schrodinger equation in
the case of a potential that
does not depend on time is a
Schrodinger equation in which
the wave function can
actually be written
as the product of a space
part times a time part
is that the probability of
finding the electron somewhere
does not depend
on time basically
because [INAUDIBLE]
square models
of psi that can also
be written as psi
times its complex conjugate.
What you have is that the
term exponential of minus i/h
gets multiplied by
its complex conjugate.
That is the exponential
of plus i/h.
And those terms cancel out.
So in the probability
distribution for the electron,
we have only the square
models of the space part.
That is to say that the
probability of finding
an electron does
not depend on time.
It's just a function of space
if the potential does not
depend on time.
You see, [INAUDIBLE]
our plane wave.
The potential does
not depend on time.
If we take the square
models of this function,
well, what we have
is really a constant
because we are just taking
an imaginary exponential
times its complex conjugate.
And so that product
is a constant.
So what we discover really
is that the electron
is free as a probability
distribution that is constant.
That is, you can find a free
electron anywhere in space.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NICOLA MARZARI: So this
is actually the solution
in three dimensions.
So what the difference is,
if you work out the algebra--
and we can look at
it after class--
is that what you have is--
in the space term, you have
really a scholar product
in three dimensions.
That is, what you
have is that now
a point in your
three-dimensional space
is described by a
three-dimensional vector r.
And now, you can have
solutions that are classified--
if you want, this k is actually
called the quantum number.
It's what classifies all
this possible continuum
of solutions.
And if you think,
k is telling you
what the wavelength
of this plane wave is
and what is its orientation.
So really, what I
am plotting here
is specific plane waves
that, if you want,
is a k vector that is
ordered in this direction.
So if we were in one dimension,
you have, if you want,
the equivalent of
a sine or a cosine.
And your only degree of
freedom is the wavelength.
But if you are in
three dimensions,
your degrees of freedom are
not only the wavelength--
that is the distance
between these crests--
but also this direction.
And any arbitrary k
vector is actually valid.
So you can have plane waves
with all possible wavelengths
and all possible orientations.
And actually, this
gives me a good chance
to mention another sort
of physical observable
that comes from
the wave function.
The first one that we have
seen is the probability
distribution.
And that's obtained by
taking the square models.
Another one is what is called
the quantum kinetic energy
of that particle.
And the quantum kinetic
energy is really just
given by minus h bar
squared divided by 2m.
So the quantum kinetic
energy is given-- well,
I'll describe it in
more detail in a moment.
But it is obtained
by really taking,
in a slightly more complex
way than what I am saying now,
the second derivative
of the wave function.
So the second derivative
here with respect
to the space of
this wave function
would give me a k square term.
That basically means that a
plane wave with all wavelengths
corresponds to electrons
with all possible energies.
But there is
something other that
is very subtle that
is reminiscent of what
in quantum mechanics people call
the indetermination principle.
So this free
electron, as you see,
is an electron that is
distributed equally in space.
So we can find it
with equal probability
here, here, or everywhere else.
And it is actually a perfectly
well-defined second derivative
with respect to space.
It has a perfectly
well-defined kinetic energy,
has a perfectly
well-defined momentum.
And that's really one example of
the indetermination principle.
That is, there is
a fundamental rule
that quantum particles satisfy.
That is, you can't
actually measure
their momentum
and their position
simultaneously with
arbitrary accuracy.
And so a free
electron, if you want,
is an electron that has
perfectly well-defined
momentum, perfectly
well-defined kinetic energy.
And for this reason, it has
perfectly undefined position.
That is, the electron
can be found anywhere.
And so this is, if you
want, an exotic result
coming from the Heisenberg
indetermination principle.
I wanted to give you
another physical example,
getting closer to reality.
Suppose that, for a moment, we
are studying a metal surface.
This wouldn't be very different
from what you have studied
in your first laboratory.
What you are studying
is basically a slab.
And you have been
finding quantities
like what is the energy, what
is the lattice parameter, what
is the surface energy.
Suppose that now you are
using quantum mechanics.
Well, what do the electrons
in the metal look like?
And we'll see in next classes
that an electron inside a metal
really feels and behaves very
much like a free particle,
especially in very
simple metals, in metals
like sodium, potassium, even
aluminum to a certain point.
There is a very
delicate cancellation
of attractive and
repulsive terms
for the electron in the metal.
So the net result, to a
very good approximation,
is that the high
energy electrons,
the valence electrons,
really feel almost free.
I'm saying almost free
because they are really
confined inside the
box that is your metal
crystal inside the box that
is given by your metal slab.
And so to have a simple but
very good approximation,
we can think of the potential
felt by an electron in a metal
as a type of potential.
I'm thinking of a case in which,
on this side, on the left,
I have really my
semi-infinite slab.
And so the potential that
is drawn by this thick line
is actually 0 for
x smaller than 0.
And then there is a confinement.
So there is a step.
This is a little
bit like a well.
There is a potential
difference v0
that contains the
electron inside the slab.
So you really need
to pay an energy v0
to get out of the slab.
But this is in physical
terms what people would
think of as the work function.
The work function
is really the energy
that you need to pay to
pick up the highest energy
electron in the metal and
bring it out, bring it very far
away from your slab.
And so to a good
approximation, the potential
that these electrons
close, as we say,
to the Fermi energy
feel is this.
And what we are
trying to find now
is a solution for the
Schrodinger equation
for a case of an electron
having an energy.
Actually, the E, that constant
in the Schrodinger equation,
is actually the total
energy of the particle.
So we are looking for a
solution for an electron having
an energy that is
basically between 0 and v0.
That means that that
electron classically
is really confined to the
left side of the potential.
And so what do we have here?
Well, what we have is that,
on the left, we have again,
a very simple
Schrodinger equation
that is minus h bar
squared over 2m d
squared over phi
equal to E times phi.
So this is, on the left side,
the Schrodinger equation
for the free particle.
And we know the solution.
And it's just being given
by one of these plane waves.
But now, the difference
is that, on the right,
we have all of a
sudden a potential.
So the equation on
the right is going
to be minus h bar squared over
2m times delta squared phi.
Remember now, in the stationary
Schrodinger equation,
we have a term that is
given by the potential that,
in this case, is just a constant
times the wave function.
And this is going to
be equal to d phi.
What's the difference
between these two equations?
Well, let me actually rewrite
the one on the right side
as minus h bar
squared over 2m delta
squared phi equal
to E minus v0 phi.
Well, in both
cases, we are trying
to find a wave function
whose second derivative
is basically equal to
the wave function itself
times a constant.
But the big difference
is that we are actually
looking for physical
solutions for an electron that
has an energy lying
somewhere in between 0--
that is our
conventional minimum--
and v0.
That is the energy cost
to get that electron out.
So what we have is that, for
the left side equation, what
we are trying to find
is a second derivative
in which, you see,
the constant is
going to be minus 2mE
over h bar squared.
So it's a negative number.
So we need to take
a second derivative
and get a function
times a negative number.
In the other case, remember,
what we are looking
is for a solution in which the
energy is between 0 and V0.
So this the sign of the
coefficient here has changed.
Here, before, it was positive.
Now, it's negative.
And with the negative
sign on the other side,
it means that what
we are looking
is for a function
whose secondary what
is equal to a positive constant
times the function itself.
And all this long
story is just to say
that the solution
on the left will
be given by an exponential
that has an i term in there.
So it's a complex exponential.
Well, the solution on
the right-hand side
will be given by
an exponential that
has a real term coefficient.
And so what we have
is on the left side
a periodic oscillatory solution
typical of the free electron.
And what we have
on the right side
is actually a
decaying exponential.
And so what we have is
that our free electron is
going to have a wave function
that really looks like this--
free particle like inside the
oscillatory and exponentially
decaying outside the surface.
And this is how truly
electrons in a metal--
and in most metals, it
looks like the wave function
decays exponentially.
That's actually why
people, say in 1981,
could invent something as
fancy as the scanning tunneling
microscope.
You see, the STM is one of
the fanciest instruments
that we have that can
actually be used to see atoms.
And what does an STM do?
Well, an STM comes with
really a nanometer-sized tip.
And what the STM measures
is the current between, say,
the metal and the tip.
And it's very
sensitive because, you
see, since the wave function
decays exponentially,
moving the tip by a small
amount will change exponentially
the current going through the
scanning tunneling microscope.
So we can actually
move this paper
and have an enormous
response in the current
to a very small displacement.
So we can actually
measure the topography
on the top of a metal
surface with great accuracy
because basically what
the scanning tunneling
microscopy is doing
is really filling up
these exponentially
decaying tails coming out
from the metal, coming out
from the metal surface.
OK.
So I'll show you just
a few examples so
that we get more and
more the feeling of how
wave functions look,
getting closer and closer
to physical problems.
Keep in mind this general idea--
if we have got
zero potential, we
have this wave-like solution.
So a typical problem that is
very simple to actually solve
analytically would be
the one in which we
have an infinite square well.
That is, we have a
particle that feels
zero potential between,
say, minus a and a
and infinite potential outside.
And this qualitatively starts
to be very similar to what
an electron in an atom feels.
And electron in an
atom doesn't really
feel a potential that is 0 in
a region and infinite outside.
It really feels an attractive
potential that is 1/r.
So the potential is actually
shaped very differently.
It's going to be a Coulombic
cusp ending up in 0.
But you see, the solutions
are very similar.
And we can understand
them better
if we actually look at the
solution for this case.
And again, what we have
is a problem in which,
between minus a and a,
we have 0 potential.
So the solutions are going to be
free electron-like, wave-like.
But now, we have
a new condition.
That is, what we have is
that being the potential
is infinite, say from this
point onwards on the right
and from this point
downwards on the left,
what we need to have
is that the wave
function needs to have 0
amplitude outside this region.
If the potential
is infinite, you
can think physically that there
is 0 probability of finding
the electron.
It's truly infinite.
So it's fully
constraining the electron.
So the wave function
needs to be 0
from here onwards and
from here onwards.
And so another great
discovery of quantum mechanics
is that the only sine
or cosine-like solutions
of the Schrodinger
equation that are
such that they have 0 amplitude
at this point and at this point
there are sines or cosines
with a wavelength that is
compatible with this distance.
So all of a sudden,
our solutions that,
in the case of
the free electron,
could have any
wavelength in the world
have now become quantized.
There is only a discrete set
of solutions with wavelengths
that are compatible with
the distance between the two
infinite, confining sides.
And this is the same concept
of an organ pipe and the music
that it plays.
When you play music in an organ
pipe, you are really exciting
either a sound wave with
a wavelength corresponding
to the fundamental harmonica.
Or the only other notes that
your organ pipe can produce
are actually higher harmonics.
And so they are,
again, sound waves
that will have 0
amplitudes at the borders.
Or same thing, say, with
the chord of a guitar.
And so the wave functions
for a confined potential
are actually quantized.
And they have
corresponding energies--
that is, in this specific case,
go actually as the square.
Although, this is less
relevant for our case.
So you will see
that, in most cases,
like when we look
at the solution
for an atom in a confining
Coulombic potential,
we'll actually find only a
discrete set of wave functions
with discrete energy levels.
And again, we can
get some hints on how
this solution would look like.
If you think for
a moment at what
would happen if our square
well, instead of having
infinite confining walls, would
have only finite confining
walls with a finite
height, it's really
the same case as
the metal surface
because now you
have a finite wall.
You have a finite wave
function decaying exponentially
outside in that region.
And so what was, you remember,
our fundamental harmonic--
the second harmonic, third
harmonic, fourth harmonic,
what were those oscillatory
solutions inside the box
now start getting these
exponential tails decaying
in the vacuum.
And this is really how
solutions for the Schrodinger
equation of an atom look like.
And I don't want really to
bore you with the algebra.
Some of you might actually have
seen this over and over again,
if you have taken
a quantum class.
I'll just give you one slide
with the conceptual framework
of what we should do if we
were to solve the Schrodinger
equation for a single
electron in what we
call a central potential.
This is a general concept.
Central potential
is a potential that
depends only on the
distance from a center,
but not on the angle
of distribution.
And so central
potential would be
written as V of r, where r
is the modulus of our vector,
is just the distance.
And the algebra
is fairly complex.
But the general idea
is that this is now
our Schrodinger equation.
We need to find a
wave function such
that the application of
the second derivative plus
this potential is
equal to the wave
function itself
times a constant.
And because somehow
we are dealing
with the geometry of
a central potential,
it's convenient to
write the Laplacian,
the second derivative, not
in Cartesian coordinate,
but in spherical coordinates--
that is, in coordinates which,
instead of giving the x, y,
and z components of a vector,
we give the distance from
the origin and the two
angles, theta and phi,
that that vector makes
with respect to different axes.
Again, the solution
is fairly complicated.
So I won't really go into this.
But this is how
our Hamiltonian--
this is how the left part
of the stationary equation
would look for this
central potential,
having just rewritten basically
this second derivative
in Cartesian coordinates.
And when one goes
through all the algebra,
one finds out that
the function--
the space part of
the wave function
can be written as a
term that depends only
on the distance from the
center, from the place where
the nucleus is, times
an angular part.
And if you are
familiar with this,
we call this angular
part spherical harmonics.
And this would be the radial
part of the wave function.
That is a solution of a slightly
different, one-dimensional
Schrodinger equation.
Again, this is just
the start, if you
are interested to take this.
But somehow, this is all
the algebra that gives rise
to the periodic table.
That is, when we
study actually what
are the solutions
of the Schrodinger
equation for a
central potential,
well, we find that we can
classify the solution as we
were classifying the solution
in the particle in a box
depending on, if you want,
the fundamental harmonic
and the higher harmonics.
Well, we can still classify
the solution depending
on the angular distribution--
so what are actually
the L and M indices
of the spherical harmonics.
And we can also classify
the radial distribution.
And so all these
possible solutions
give us all the possible states
of an electron in a hydrogen
atom.
And you probably have seen
this over and over again.
But it's really the fundamental
alphabet that gives rise
to the periodic table.
So for the hydrogen atom,
the fundamental solution
is one in which the
electron is distributed
with spherical symmetry
around the nucleus.
And if we look at the
probability density
as a function of the
distance from the center,
it's something that really
looks a little bit like this.
So the probability of finding
the electron in the hydrogen
atom at a certain
distance really
has a maximum at a distance that
is, I believe, at 1.5 bohrs.
I need to check
actually this number.
The classical radius of the
hydrogen atom is 1 bohr.
It's 0.529 Angstrom.
And the maximum, I
think, is at 1.5.
But basically, there is
a maximum of probability.
And then it decays again.
But then there is
a whole zoology
of excited states that
can have, say, a more
complex radial part.
And we classify these--
you probably remember
this from your chemistry.
We call this state
a 1s state where
1 really refers
to the radial part
and s refers to
the angular part.
And the next state would
be a 2s-like state,
in which, being s, the angular
part is still the same.
It's spherically symmetric.
But now, the radial
part has changed.
And it actually changed sign.
So it goes inside.
Then it goes back to 0.
Then it goes again.
And it goes back to 0.
And then there are
states like the 2p states
in which the angular part
starts to play a role.
And so this would be a specific
p state that, if you want,
has two lobes with
opposite signs
across a plane of symmetry.
And then there are more complex
states like the d states
and so on and so forth.
And a very important thing
is that really this angular
symmetry comes from just having
considered a central potential.
That is a potential
that doesn't depend
from the angular variable,
but just from the distance.
And so these solutions have
the same qualitative difference
not only for a single
electron in a hydrogen atom,
but, say, in general for an
electron in an atom where
really that electron
will feel not
only the attractive
potential of the nucleus,
but also the repulsive potential
from all the other electrons.
But to a great extent,
that repulsive potential
of all the other
electrons is going
to be a fairly spherical
symmetry kind of potential
because all the other electrons,
when you take their charge
density, are going to
be roughly spherically
symmetrically distributed.
And so the solution
really, for one electron
in a central potential,
does not only apply
to the hydrogen
atom, but applies
to really any atom
in the periodic table
to some approximation.
That is to the approximation
that we consider.
The repulsive potential
that all the other electrons
have for this, say, top valance
electron in a generic atom, say
iron, is that the
only approximation
is that these repulsive
potential is also
spherically symmetric.
That is not true but is
true to a very large extent.
OK.
Now, this concludes, if you
want, our general panorama
on what is quantum mechanics.
And now, really, we want to
go into electronic structure
methods.
That is, we want to arrive at
what is called the Hartree-Fock
solution.
That is, again, one of the
fundamental techniques,
especially in quantum chemistry.
And to do this, I
need to give you
a little bit of nomenclature.
Again, if you have never seen
a set of quantum mechanics
or if you have never taken
a quantum mechanics class,
it would be very useful to have
a look at some of the books
that I've given you in
the bibliography, either
some fundamental books
like Quantum Mechanics
or Physics of Atoms
and Molecules,
both by Bransden and Joachain,
that are very good quantum
mechanics books, or some of
the electronic structure books,
like the Phoenix books
on inter-atomic forces
or the Richard Martin
book, or the Kaxiras book.
But the nomenclature that
we'll use over and over again
is what is called the bracket
nomenclature of the Dirac.
And so in general,
a wave function
is actually represented
by this sign here.
This is called [INAUDIBLE].
Again, that means nothing
else than our function.
That is an amplitude
defined everywhere
in space or everywhere
in space and time.
And in general, it's
a complex amplitude.
And now, one of the fundamentals
of the rules of quantum
mechanics is that,
say, a wave function
corresponding to different
states of an electron--
say you are considering the
function for the ground state
of the hydrogen atom, the 1s.
And then you are considering the
function for an excited state,
like the 2s.
So the wave function
for different states
are going to be orthonormal.
What does it mean?
It means that when we
take the scalar product,
that scalar product is
going to be either 0 or 1,
depending if we are taking the
scalar product with the wave
function itself or with the wave
function of a different state.
So this delta ij is what is
called usually a chronicle
delta.
It's a symbol that means this
is going to be equal to 1
if i is equal to j or is
going to be equal to 0
if i is different from j.
And the scalar product
between two wave functions
is written in shorthand
notation as this.
It's written as a bra
times a ket, a bracket.
But again, that's nothing
else than a shorthand
form for the proper definition
of the scalar product.
Again, you are probably not
heard of Hilbert spaces.
But this is a vector
space of wave function
that has a metric defined.
And so we can define something
like a scalar product
by taking the integral
of the wave function
on the left that
has been complex
conjugated times the wave
function on the right.
So all wave functions that
are solutions of a Schrodinger
equation satisfy this
orthonormality normality
property.
If you take this integral,
that is going to be equal to 1
if you are just taking the
square of the wave function.
And it's going to be equal
to 0 if i is different to j.
And you see why it's
equal to 1 actually
if i is equal to
j because remember
what is psi i star times psi i?
Well, it's just a
square modulus of psi i.
So psi i star times psi i in
a certain point r in space
gives me the probability
of finding the electron
in point in space.
And when I integrate that
probability all over space,
it becomes obvious that
that number must be 1
because what is the probability
of finding an electron anywhere
in space?
Well, you'll find it somewhere.
So the probability of
finding it anywhere--
that is the integral of psi
squared as a function of r--
must be equal to 1.
So that's the
physical connection.
And the last
definition that I need
is that of expectation values.
That is, once we
have found a wave
function for this electron--
as I said, we know
everything that we need
to know about that electron.
And so we can extract all
the physical properties
that we want.
It's like, in
classical mechanics,
if you have the trajectory
of your electrons,
you can calculate at any instant
in time what is, say, 1/2 times
the mass times the
square velocity.
That would be the kinetic
energy of that particle.
Similarly, if you know the
wave function of that electron,
you can calculate any
kind of physical quantity.
And one of the most important
physical quantities,
apart from the probability
of finding it somewhere,
is what is the energy
of that electron.
And this is the shorthand term
in the bracket nomenclature
of what would be the
energy of an electron.
We call this an
expectation value.
So in quantum mechanics, for
every physical observable,
like the energy, there is
going to be an operator that
acts on the wave function and
is such that its expectation
value gives me the physical
quantity I'm interested in.
So if I want to know the energy
of an electron that has a wave
function psi i, I need to
calculate this expectation
value, psi h psi i--
that will give me the energy.
And the quantum
mechanical operator
that gives me the energy is
what is called the Hamiltonian
operator, h, that
I've written here.
So the Hamiltonian
operator is nothing else.
And I forgot it here.
And sorry, there is a Laplacina.
The Hamiltonian
operator is nothing
else what we have seen in
the Schrodinger equation.
It's minus h bar squared
divided by 2m times
the Laplacian plus
the potential.
So if you want to
calculate what is
the energy of this electron,
what you need to do
is to apply the energy operator,
that is the Hamiltonian,
to the wave function.
So you need to take the
second derivative with respect
to the wave function.
With the appropriate
coefficient,
you need to sum the potential
times the wave function.
And now, to this
new quantity that
is again a field that
is a function of r,
well, you need to
take that multiplied
by the complex conjugate
of the wave function
and integrate it all over space.
So if you want, it's a much
more complex operation.
But that's exactly what are
the rules for quantum objects.
You have a Schrodinger equation.
You find its solutions.
And then the solutions are the
ground state or the excited
state wave function.
And if you want
to calculate what
are the physical
values of what we
say are observable
quantities, like the energy,
you need to take an
expectation value
of the appropriate operator.
And if you want the most
fundamental operator,
it's the Hamiltonian h
that is just written here.
And the expectation value that
is written in shorthand form
here is nothing else but
the integral overall space
of the complex
conjugate of the wave
function times what we obtain
by applying to the wave
function the
Hamiltonian operator.
And we integrate that in space.
Now, it's actually
simpler than it
looks because
remember for a moment
that this psi is actually a
solution of the Schrodinger
equation.
This psi is a solution of
the stationary Schrodinger
equation.
So we know already, because
the Hamiltonian is really--
remember, it's the
left and term that
is in this stationary equation.
So we know already that,
by the fact of this
being the solution, applying
this operator to this wave
function is going to
give me a constant times
this wave function.
And so the concept, we
call it nothing else than E
with a subscript i.
So this times the wave function
gives me a constant times
the wave function itself.
And I can take the constant
out of the integral sine.
And I'm left with constant E of
phi times the integral of psi i
star times Ci.
And that's nothing else than 1.
And so this is, if you
want, the explicit solution
of why this is epsilon i.
Of course, if you
have never seen this,
it might look very arcane.
And this is why I urge you to
read some introductory quantum
mechanics textbooks.
If you have seen it already, of
course, it might seem trivial.
It might seem trivial to you.
OK.
And now, in the next
three or four slides,
we go really into the
two fundamental concepts
of computational
electronic structure.
That involves two things.
One, it involves finding the
solution of the Schrodinger
equation on a computer--
that is, on a system
that is really not able to
do analysis, if you want,
is not able to do
analytic derivatives
and analytic integrals.
And so we'll how we
actually deal in practice
with this issue.
And then in the
second set of slides,
we'll give you the
fundamental concept
that is a reformulation of
the differential equation,
of the Schrodinger equation,
in a different form that
is actually computer-friendly
and algorithmic-friendly.
So we have a
Schrodinger equation
that we know we need to solve.
But we can actually
rewrite it in a form
that is much more convenient.
And respectively,
you can think of them
as the general concept of
expanding wave function
in a basis that transforms
all our analysis and integrals
and differentials
in matrix algebra.
And I'll show you in a
moment why that is the case.
And in the second
part, we'll see
how the Schrodinger
equation is transformed
into a variational principle.
So really, what you are
seeing now is, I would say,
the central content
of today's class.
OK.
Let me first go back to
the Schrodinger equation
as you have seen it before.
And now, I'm using
actually the shorthand term
H, this Hamiltonian operator,
that is again nothing
less than minus H bar
squared over 2m times
the Laplacian plus
the potential.
And so the Schrodinger
equation tells us
that, for a given potential,
we need to find a wave function
psi such that when
we apply on it
those derivatives and
those multiplication
contained in the
Hamiltonian operator, that
is H, what we obtain
is nothing else
but the wave function
itself times a constant.
So this is the Schrodinger
equation in shorthand form.
And we can even be more
compact and write it
in the bracket formulation
on the right side
as H psi equal to epsilon psi.
So this is our
Schrodinger equation.
And now, this is the
fundamental step.
And this is what
really makes all
of this solvable on a computer.
What we say now is that
any generic wave function--
OK.
So we are still
considering one electron
in three dimensional space.
So what we have is really an
amplitude field all over space.
Well, that amplitude
field can actually
be written as a
linear combination
of an infinite number of simple
functions times a coefficient.
So we are saying, well, we can
expand every possible field
into a linear combination
of orthogonal functions
that would be our
basis function.
Say, if you have seen
Fourier analysis,
you have seen that,
in most cases,
a well-behaved
function can actually
be expanded as a linear
combination of sines
and cosines.
Or in general, if you have
seen more of analysis,
you have seen that, in a
lot of these Hilbert spaces,
you can define what are
called complete sets
of orthogonal functions.
Sines and cosines are a complete
set of orthogonal functions.
If you take sines or cosines
with different wavelengths
and you integrate
them over a space,
you get 0 unless the
wavelength is the same.
And by using an infinite
number of sines and cosines
with different wavelengths,
you can describe any function
that is, in some ways, smooth
enough, that doesn't, say,
infinite discontinuities.
And so what we do
really, in most
of our computational
application,
is that we define a basis set.
Let's say, for the
case of solids,
it's actually going exactly
to be the basis set of plane
waves, those E to the i kr
with all possible wavelength
and with all
possible directions.
That is an orthogonal set.
And it's complete.
And so once we decide
what is our basis set,
say sines and cosines,
and plane waves--
and there are a lot more that
I'll describe in the following.
Well, at that
point, our function
needs to be specified by
a set of coefficients.
And in all practical
implementation,
we won't use infinite sets.
If you have got a
well-behaved function,
you don't need to describe--
it probably won't
have oscillation
with extremely thin wavelength.
So you can expand
a wave function
into a combination
of sines and cosines
that have progressively shorter
and shorter wavelengths.
But at a certain point, you
can say, well, I'll stop here.
I don't need a resolution
that is thinner than what
is physically reasonable.
I mean, if you are
looking at electrons,
well, they are going
to have oscillations
that are of the order of
the inter-atomic distance.
But they are not going
to have oscillations
that are of the order, say,
of the diameter of a nucleus.
It just doesn't make
any physical sense.
So you can understand, for
every physical problem at hand,
when you can actually stop
this infinite expansion
in your orthogonal basis.
And at that point,
your wave function
becomes defined just by a
finite number of coefficients.
And so suppose that
for a moment you
have only 10 basis functions.
It could be sine of x, sine
of 2x, sine of 3x, sine of 4x,
up to sine of 10x
in one dimension.
Well, once you have decided that
those 10 are your good basis
function, your wave function
is described by 10 numbers.
It's just a vector.
And so what you need to do
is find those 10 numbers.
So if you want, what
was an analysis problem
now becomes a bit of a linear
algebra problem in the ways
you'll see in a moment,
in which we really need
to find those 10 coefficients.
We don't need to find
any more integrals
and derivatives of functions.
And so let's actually
see how this develops.
Remember, what we need to solve
is the Schrodinger equation
that I've written over here.
And now, I have decided that
I've got an orthogonal basis.
And I am going to
do some algebra.
In particular, I take this
Schrodinger equation above.
Remember, it's operator
applied on the wave
function equal to a constant
times the wave function.
And what I do is I say
I multiply this relation
on the left and on the right by
the complex conjugate of phi m.
So in going from here
to here, what I do
is I multiply this times the
complex conjugate of phi m.
So it's phi m star.
And then I integrate
everything over space.
And so you see,
when I take H psi,
I multiply it by phi m star.
And I integrate.
What I obtain is something
that, in shorthand bracket
formulation, can be
written as phi m H psi
This is nothing less
than a shorthand
for the integral of overall
space of phi star m times
what results from
applying H to psi.
Same to the right-hand side--
I multiply E times
by phi m star.
And I integrate over space.
Now, E is just a constant.
So it can come out
of the integral sine.
And what I am left
with is the integral
of phi m star times psi.
And again, it's very important
that you go back just
after this class and
you rewrite explicitly
all these algebraic terms
to make sure that you
become comfortable with them.
So I've done this operation.
This is what I have obtained.
And now, what I do I
exploit my hypothesis.
I've said that my
wave function can
be written as a linear
combination of my basis
function with
certain coefficients.
So in this integral,
now I substitute for psi
at sum of wave function with
appropriate coefficients.
And as usual, I can take
the sum and the coefficient
out of the integral sine.
So what I'm left with
is a sum of the Cn that
multiplies the integral of
phi star m H phi star n.
This is what I have
on the left-hand side.
And now, on the right-hand side,
this is likely trickier to see.
Again, I'm substituting
for psi that sum.
So what I obtain
here is really--
let me write it as an
integral for a moment--
is the integral over all
space of phi m star times
the sum over n of Cn phi m.
I can take a--
sorry, it's a sum over--
it's a bit difficult to see.
Let me write it more clearly.
It's a sum over n Cn phi star n.
OK.
These are just coefficients.
I can take them out
of the integral sine.
So what I'm left with
is sum over n Cn times
the integral over the r
of phi n star times phi m.
For some reason, I
wrote this down here.
So it's just a phi n.
And now, the integral
of dr phi m star
times phi n is going to be
equal either to 1 or to 0,
depending if m is equal to
Min or m is different from n
because, in our hypothesis,
we have said that these basis
functions are orthogonal.
And that orthogonal means we
take the integral of them.
If they are
identical, it gives 1.
different, it gives 0.
So in all the sum
over the n, there
is only one index that
will be identical to this.
So for that case,
the integral gives 1.
Otherwise, it gives 0.
So what is saved
in all of this is
only the coefficient
that corresponds
to this m coefficient here.
So what we obtain from this
is the Cm times a constant.
OK.
So again, I've rewritten
the Schrodinger equation
by multiplying it by phi
m star, integrating it.
And what I obtain
is a new formulation
of the Schrodinger equation that
I have also in the next slide.
And that we are actually
going to analyze.
So this is nothing else
than your last slide.
And again, what we need to
find are these coefficiencies.
Those have become
now our solution.
And we can actually write
this explicitly using
a bit of nomenclature.
That is, we can call that
scalar, that expectation
value--
phi m H phi n, we can call
it that shorthand H m n.
We call it actually
the matrix element
of the Hamiltonian over the
two basis phi m and phi n.
And so again, our
Schrodinger equation
has been rewritten in
compact form as this.
That is, the physical
problem tells
us what is the potential
that the electron feels.
The potential specifies what
the Hamiltonian operator
H is because it's,
again, just the Laplacian
plus the potential.
And so once we have
decided our basis set
onto which we develop
our wave function, what
we need to calculate are
all these matrix elements.
Now, these H m n are
explicit numbers.
Once my potential
is well-defined,
once my bases sector is defined,
those H are just numbers.
And they actually can be
written out in a matrix.
And my Schrodinger equation has
been rewritten in this form.
That is, I have that this matrix
times the vector of coefficient
of my expansion needs
to be equal to a number
times the same vector.
And if you want, I have
two things to find out.
I need to find out what
are the values of E
for which this linear algebra
system is a solution at all.
And we know from linear
algebra that there
aren't an infinite
number of values of E
for which this system
has a solution.
And I'll comment in
that on a moment.
And once we have found
those values of E
for which there is a solution,
we need to find the solution.
That is, we need to
find this vector.
And so again, our
problem is matrix times
vector needs to be equal
to a constant times vector.
And we actually-- again,
I don't have the time
to go into linear algebra.
But we know this can actually
be rewritten as a Hamiltonian
matrix, an H matrix minus an
E on all the diagonal terms
times this vector equal to 0.
And we know that this
linear algebra solution--
this linear algebra
problem has a solution
only for values of E such that
the determinant of the matrix H
minus E times the identity is 0.
So our goal is first finding
those values of E for which
this determinant is 0.
And we call those eigenvalues,
are the only values
of the energy that are allowed
in our quantized Schrodinger
equation.
And then for each of
these eigenvalues, E,
there is going to be a vector.
There is going to be a set
of coefficient from C1 and Ck
that satisfies this
linear algebra problem.
And we call that specific vector
of coefficients an eigenvector.
So this is an
eigenvalue equation
that only certain
values of phi which
this equation is a solution.
And those values of phi
for which it has a solution
will give rise to
the eigenvector
that satisfies this equation.
And in a computer, you see the
only thing that we need to do
is calculate this matrix
element of the Hamiltonian,
find its eigenvalue, and
find its eigenvectors that
are all well-defined
linear algebra problems.
And so this is the first
fundamental conclusion.
We can always rewrite our
quantum mechanical problem
into a linear algebra
problem once we specify
a basis set for our function.
And depending on
the problem at hand,
we can choose basis sets that
are more appropriate or less
appropriate.
If we are studying, say,
electrons in a metal
that would look like
free electron-like,
a basis set of plane waves
with different wavelengths
is a very good choice.
If we are studying solutions,
say, in a molecule,
maybe a basis set in which
each state looks more
like atomic orbitals would
be a more appropriate choice.
And again, we'll see
this in the next classes.
But now, the problem has become
a linear algebra problem.
And there is another conceptual
and last step for today's class
that I want to highlight.
That is very powerful
because, especially when
we move from trying to find the
solution for a single electron
to finding the solution for
many interacting electrons,
it will give us a
systematic handle
to move in a problem
that becomes conceptually
more and more complex.
We have discussed how there is
this exponentially exploding
complexity.
And there is what is called
a variational principle.
That is nothing else
but reformulation
of the Schrodinger equation.
And what is this?
Well, what I am
saying is that there
is what we call a functional
of any arbitrary function.
What is a functional?
Well, it's something
that, given a function,
operates on that function
and produces a number.
So we call our
functional E of phi.
It's an algorithm that
eats as input a function
and gives as output a number.
And the explicitly
definition of this algorithm
is given here on
the right-hand side.
And what is it?
Well, for any arbitrary
function, what we need
is to calculate the expectation
value of the Hamiltonian.
So we need to calculate
again the integral
over space of phi star times
the Hamiltonian operator applied
onto phi.
And we divide that this by the
integral of phi star times phi.
OK.
This is an operative definition.
I gave you a function.
What you obtain back by
calculating this integral
and taking the
ratio is a number.
But now, the important
thing is, what can we prove?
Well, we can prove this
fundamental theorem that tells
us, for a given
Hamiltonian-- that is,
for a given potential--
you can throw into this
functional any arbitrary
function.
You can try to calculate
this ratio for any phi.
And what you'll find
is that the number
that you obtain for any
phi that you throw in
is going to be always greater
or equal than the ground state
energy of your electron.
Not only that, but in
particular this number
is equal to the ground state
energy of your electron,
the function that you have used
is really the ground state wave
function, is the wave
function corresponding
to the lowest energy of
the Schrodinger equation.
And so you see this gives
us a sort of trial and error
practical recipe to try and find
out what is the ground state
energy of an electron in
very complex potential
because the only thing
that we have to do
is try a lot of wave functions.
And what we will
obtain as our best
guess is the wave function that
has the minimum expectation
value.
It will never be
an exact solution,
unless we examine
all the possible wave
functions in the world.
But it's a solution that
becomes better and better
the more systematic we become.
The more wave functions
we try, the better
our solution will
be, the closer it
will be to the
ground state energy.
And I think I'll leave
it as an exercise--
and this is my last slide--
to be proven by
you for next time.
And that is, I'm asking you
to go back and try to prove
this variational principle.
And the only operation
that you really need to do
is, again, expand
your wave function phi
into a linear
combination now of states
that I can call chi
of n that are actually
the eigenstates of
the Hamiltonian.
That is, we have a well-defined
Hamiltonian operator.
So in principle,
at least formally,
we know that it will
have a set of solutions
that we write as H applied
to this eigenfunction
is going to be a number times
the eigenfunction itself.
And the set of solutions
of a Hamiltonian
are actually in themselves
a complete orthonormal set.
So we use that
complete orthonormal
set to expand our wave function
as a linear combination
of these eigenvectors.
And with this ansatz,
wave function expanded
in a combination
of eigenfunctions
of the Hamiltonian, you can
go back and prove by yourself
the variational principle
in the previous slide.
And that, again, is probably
the most powerful principle
that we have to develop
all the many-body solutions
to the electronic
structure problem.
And we'll see that in
next class on Thursday.
And again, all of
this, if you have never
seen quantum mechanics,
might seem very Arcane.
So either read some
of the readings
that I have given you
or just come and see me.
Fix up an appointment.